Three, two, one, clap. You were a full two seconds late for that, bro. There's this thing called latency. There's this thing called latency. It's not important that it's at the same... Well, do you want to do it again? Three, two, one, clap. There we go. Nailed it.
三、二、一，拍手。你刚才慢了整整两秒钟，兄弟。这有个东西叫延迟。这有个东西叫延迟。不在同一个节奏上并不重要……好吧，你想再来一次吗？三、二、一，拍手。好了。完美搞定。
Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 14, recorded on February 13th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about inclusive terminology. Because that's the thing, they introduced the ribbon and a bunch of new shortcuts for everything, but they grandfathered in. Is that an inclusive term, grandfathered? I'm not sure. No, it's not. We're going to take a brief tangent for me to explain why grandfathered is problematic. One of the things I've been working on recently is I'm the de facto editor for these inclusive terminology guidelines for the insights and tech specs. And the document lists a bunch of terms you should avoid. There's only one term that has a lengthy explanation because all the other ones are fairly straightforward why they're problematic
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 14 期，录制于 2021 年 2 月 13 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论包容性术语。因为是这样的，他们引入功能区（ribbon）和一堆用于各种操作的新快捷键，但他们沿用了“祖父条款”（grandfathered）。这是一个包容性的词吗，“grandfathered”？我不确定。不，它不是。我们要简单偏离一下主题，让我来解释一下为什么“grandfathered”是有问题的。我最近一直在做的事情之一，就是担任 Insights 和技术规范中这些包容性术语指南的默认编辑。该文档列出了一堆你应该避免使用的词汇。其中只有一个词有冗长的解释，因为其他所有词汇为什么有问题都相当直观，
and so they don't need an explanation. But we had to add a lengthy one for grandfathered because people kept asking why it was problematic. So I'll just explain here just so that more people know and fewer people ask me. A grandfather clause was a type of law that was passed in the American South post-Civil War that was intended to suppress the ability of African Americans to vote. So the basic idea is you would pass a law that says to be eligible to vote, your grandfather must have been eligible to vote. And if you were
所以它们不需要解释。但我们不得不为“grandfathered”添加一个很长的解释，因为人们一直问为什么它有问题。所以我在这里解释一下，好让更多人知道，少点人来问我。“祖父条款”（grandfather clause）是美国内战后南部各州通过的一种法律，旨在压制非裔美国人的投票权。所以其基本理念是，你通过一项法律，规定要获得投票资格，你的祖父必须具备投票资格。如果你是
somebody who was a slave and who was freed after the Civil War and your parents were probably slaves and your grandparents were slaves, then you would not be eligible to vote so essentially it was a law that said black people can't vote just you know goes through some uh some hoops to get there so yeah don't use grandfathered grandfather clause grandfathering um those terms are now grandfathered that is uh that is way worse than i like clearly grandfathered is a gendered term which is is why immediately when I... Yeah, and that's what everybody immediately thinks. They think either gendered or that it's ageist.
某个在内战后获得自由的奴隶，你的父母可能是奴隶，你的祖父母是奴隶，那么你就没有资格投票。所以本质上，这是一项规定黑人不能投票的法律，只是你知道的，通过一些花招来达到这个目的。所以，是的，不要使用 grandfathered、grandfather clause、grandfathering……这些词现在被“grandfathered”（祖父化）了……这比我……显然，grandfathered 是一个有性别倾向的词，这就是为什么我一听到……是的，这也是每个人立刻想到的。他们要么想到有性别倾向，要么想到有年龄歧视。
Pete, that's what people's reaction is. But no, it can be those things too, but it's also racist. So that's the thing. I immediately said it because that is the word that was stored in my brain. And then as soon as I said it, I was like, oh, wait, yeah, that that's gendered probably not inclusive uh and so then i asked i was not expecting that um so yeah that is and so what is there uh what's are we gonna what are we gonna brainstorm what's the alternative um hang on i i ironically i had that the document open in another tab because i was working on it this morning the alternatives that we recommend are legacy or historical.
皮特（Pete），大家的反应就是这样。但不是的，它也可以是那些，但它也是种族主义的。所以就是这样。我马上说出来，是因为那是存储在我大脑里的词。然后我一说出来，我就想，哦，等等，是的，那是带有性别倾向的，可能不够包容。然后我问了，我当时没料到那个……所以，是的，就是这样。那么有什么……有什么……我们要讨论什么，我们要集思广益什么，替代方案是什么？等一下，讽刺的是，我另一个标签页里恰好打开了那个文档，因为我今天早上正在处理它。我们推荐的替代方案是 legacy（遗留的）或 historical（历史的）。
Yeah, legacy shortcuts. Yeah, that's good. The 2003 legacy shortcuts. And if anybody has better ideas for alternatives, send me a DM or smoke smoke. Well, not that I want to you know veer off of talking about Mono but I have a question. What is the alternative to first-class? That's this is like the biggest Ironically that is actually the entry right after grandfather than this document. So I don't even have to scroll
对，legacy 快捷键。对，这很好。2003 年的 legacy 快捷键。如果任何人有更好的替代方案想法，发私信给我或者用烟雾……好吧，并不是说我想偏离讨论 Mono 的话题，但我有一个问题。first-class 的替代方案是什么？这是最大的……讽刺的是，这实际上是文档中“grandfathered”之后的下一个条目。所以我甚至都不用滚动页面。
So the reason that first class is problematic is that you know it has connotations of you know political or societal systems where there's inherent striation you know like where there's like one one type of people has more rights than other types of people. So the alternatives that we suggest is if you're just using first class with then something like core built-in top level, I think I got all of those from the Google documentation guide, their section on inclusive terminology. And if you're using the term like first class citizen, you could potentially replace citizen with entity, feature, facility, something like that.
所以，first-class（一等/头等）之所以有问题，是因为你知道它带有政治或社会制度的内涵，其中存在固有的等级划分，你知道的，比如某种类型的人比其他类型的人享有更多权利。因此，我们建议的替代方案是，如果你只是将 first-class 与某些东西结合使用，比如 core（核心）、built-in（内置）、top-level（顶级），我想这些我都取自谷歌的文档指南，即他们关于包容性术语的章节。如果你使用的是诸如 first-class citizen（一等公民）之类的术语，你或许可以把 citizen 替换为 entity（实体）、feature（特性）、facility（设施）之类的主意。
So I've been using like top level a lot as a replacement. It is a term that comes up a lot in programming languages because we often talk about first class entities in a programming language, which is something that's sort of, you know, like we talk about whether or not a programming language, whether functions are first class or not, whether you can store a function to a variable, et cetera. Like in C++, functions are not class or not, whether you can store a function to a variable, etc. Like in C++, functions are not top level, but in a lot of functional programming languages,
所以我经常使用 top-level 作为替代方案。这是编程语言中经常出现的一个词，因为我们经常在编程语言中谈论一等实体（first-class entities），也就是某种类似于，你知道的，我们在讨论一门编程语言时，函数是否是一等的，是否可以将函数存储到变量中，等等。比如在 C++ 中，函数不是一等的，但在许多函数式编程语言中，
they are. So it is certainly something that I think you and I as programming language geeks come across more frequently. Well, so yeah, I don't want to be controversial but like i am i'm completely on board with you know master domain you know blacklist whitelist to allow list deny list uh grandfather to legacy those make zero difference for me um and and obviously it makes or it's more inclusive and it makes it makes more people feel comfortable um whatever. So it does make a difference to me. It's better to use the alternative.
它们是。所以这当然是我和你作为编程语言极客更常遇到的事情。好吧，所以，是的，我不想引起争议，但我……我完全赞同，你知道的，主分支/从分支（master/domain）、黑名单/白名单改为允许列表/拒绝列表、grandfather 改为 legacy，这些对我来说完全没有任何区别……而且很明显，这带来了改变，它更具包容性，让更多人感到舒适，无论如何。所以这对我有区别。使用替代方案更好。
First class, all of those alternatives cause confusion. So I'm in the midst of listening to the most recent Lex Friedman podcast where they've got Brandon Eich. He has Brandon Eich on who's the JavaScript creator and later went on to work at Mozilla and is now working at Brave. They've probably used the word first class, like, I wouldn't be surprised.
First-class，所有这些替代方案都会引起困惑。所以我正在听最近的 Lex Friedman 播客，他们请到了布兰登·艾奇（Brandon Eich）。他请到了布兰登·艾奇，他是 JavaScript 的创造者，后来在 Mozilla 工作，现在在 Brave 工作。他们可能用过 first-class 这个词，我不觉得奇怪，
I'm not exaggerating, like, 50-plus times, because when asked, you know, what do you think the best thing is about JavaScript that you got right in the early days when he wrote it in, you know, 10 days was, like, sort of the story, he said first class functions functions, first-class functions. And, and I've recently encountered, uh, the term types as values. And I didn't understand that for like two weeks because I didn't understand that what they meant as types as values was first class types and um i like so i'm i'm so
我没有夸张，大概用了 50 多次，因为当被问到，你知道的，你认为 JavaScript 最棒的地方是什么，你在早期花了大约 10 天时间写出它时的故事是什么，他说的是一等函数（first-class functions），一等函数。而且我最近遇到了“作为值的类型”（types as values）这个术语。我大约有两周时间没搞懂它，因为我不明白他们所说的“作为值的类型”其实就是一等类型（first-class types），而且我……我很……
i'm completely for like finding a way to use more inclusive language but when it comes to this i'm not saying i'm not on board i just i'm just conflicted about it because when you're when you're when you're causing confusion like first class functions explicit has an explicit meaning and saying top level functions, to me, something got lost and I don't actually know what you're talking about. Yeah, but the issue here is that it's an established term of art. There's a difference with grandfathered, which is grandfathered is a term that has usage outside of CS and it doesn't really have a specific usage within CS. Whereas talking about
我完全支持寻找一种使用更多包容性语言的方法，但当谈到这一点时，我并不是说我不支持，我只是对此感到矛盾。因为当你……当你……当你引起混淆时，比如 first-class functions 有着明确的含义，而说 top-level functions，对我来说，有些东西丢失了，我其实不知道你在说什么。是的，但这里的问题在于，这是一个既定的专业术语（term of art）。这与 grandfathered 不同，grandfathered 是一个在计算机科学（CS）之外有使用的词，并且它在计算机科学内部并没有真正特定的用法。然而谈到
a first class functions, that is a specific term of art specific to our field. And it is much harder to replace a specific term of art that is specific to our field. The reason is because why do we coin terms of art? The reason that we coin terms of art is that there's not a good word in the broader language for it. So something like grandfathered is much, much, much easier to replace because it's not a specific term of art
一等函数（first-class functions），那是我们领域特有的特定专业术语。要替换我们领域特有的专业术语要困难得多。原因在于，我们为什么创造专业术语？我们创造专业术语的原因是，更广泛的语言中没有一个好的词来表达它。所以像 grandfathered 这样的话题要容易得多、容易得多、容易得多去替换，因为它不是我们行业的特定专业术语。
to our industry. It's not something that needed a specific word. So there's plenty of other candidates. Whereas something that is an established term of art is a lot more challenging to replace. So I'll agree with you on that. So as an industry, as whatever, a group of professionals in industry and academia, is there still a push? Because I don't know how many people listen to Lex Friedman, but he often quotes that it's like hundreds of thousands.
它不是一个需要特定单词的事物。所以还有很多其他的候选词。而已经确立的专业术语则更具挑战性，难以替换。所以在这点上我同意你的看法。那么作为一个行业，作为一个……无论如何，作为行业和学术界的一群专业人士，是否仍然在推动这种改变？因为我不知道有多少人听 Lex Friedman，但他经常引用说有几十万。
And so hundreds of thousands of people are, you know, potentially for the first time as, you know, working in a certain language or as junior developers in university, they're hearing first class functions for like the first time. So like, I'm guessing that there's like a non-trivial amount of folks that in the next couple of days are going to hear first class functions for the first time. So like what is like do we give up and just say, well, for first class functions, we say it's a term of art. It's OK. Or do we say, no, this is just going to be a long battle and we agree that we're going to relabel it to something. And then, you know, after a decade, it happens yeah so the the current guidance that we're giving within standards is when it's a
所以有几十万人，你知道的，可能是在学习某种特定语言时，或者作为大学里的初级开发人员，这是他们第一次听到一等函数（first-class functions）。所以我想，在接下来的几天里，肯定会有相当数量的人第一次听到一等函数。那么，我们是放弃并说，好吧，对于一等函数，我们说这是一个专业术语，没关系？还是说，不，这注定是一场漫长的斗争，我们同意将其改名为其他东西，然后，你知道的，十年后它会发生？是的，所以我们在标准中给出的当前指导原则是，当它是一个
term of art um uh you should introduce a new term of art and then when you're using the new term of art you can say you know previously known as or otherwise known as, you know, old term of art. Interesting. Yeah. I mean, it's the same sort of problem when you're replacing a problematic word that has semantic meaning. You know, when there's something that's a keyword or where it's not just something that is a documentation change, it's an actual, you know, code change to replace the term. You know, if it's a code change to change the term, then that means that it's probably not something that you can necessarily do overnight. And in which case our guidance is, you know,
专业术语时，你应该引入一个新的专业术语，然后当你使用这个新的专业术语时，你可以说，你知道的，以前称为（previously known as）或别名（otherwise known as）旧的专业术语。有意思。是的。我的意思是，当你替换一个具有语义的有问题的词时，也会遇到同样的问题。你知道，当某个词是关键字，或者不仅仅是文档更改，而是实际的代码更改来替换该术语时。你知道，如果更改该术语需要进行代码更改，那就意味着这可能不是你一定能一蹴而就的事情。在这种情况下，我们的指导原则是，你知道的，
well, you can try to replace it if possible. And if you can't replace it immediately, then, you know, introduce an alias for it, a new word for it. You can continue to support the old word, but in all new material, you should use the new term. And then you should try to move towards deprecating the old term. It's the same problem for terms of art. Yeah, that's going to be a long, that's a long road for some of those um yeah because that's the thing is yeah most most of them you know some people make a stink about it and i'm like literally like it makes zero difference like right right right what you're saying what you're saying is what you're saying is that there's very low cost in most cases to moving towards a new
好吧，如果可能的话，你可以尝试替换它。如果无法立即替换，那么，你知道的，为它引入一个别名，一个新词。你可以继续支持旧词，但在所有新材料中，你应该使用新术语。然后你应该努力逐步淘汰（deprecate）旧术语。专业术语也是同样的问题。是的，对于其中一些词来说，这将是一条漫长的道路……是的，因为这就是问题所在……是的，大多数人……有些人会大惊小怪，而我真的觉得……就像……这完全没有区别……对，对，对，你所说的是，在大多数情况下，转向一个新术语的成本非常低。
term yeah exactly yeah literally like, literally like going to GitHub and changing your master branch to main is literally like it takes two seconds and then people just have to repoint it locally. That one's a bad example though because that one is one that requires a code change because there might be old existing references that are pointing towards main.
是的，完全正确。是的，简直就像……简直就像去 GitHub 把你的 master 分支改成 main 一样，真的是只需要两秒钟，然后人们只需要在本地重新指向它。不过这个例子不太好，因为那个例子确实需要更改代码，因为可能存在指向 main 的旧有现有引用。
A better example is if you're using something solely in documentation. That is absolutely 100% free. If it's just a word that you're using to describe something, that's totally free to change. Or if it's in something that that you're using to describe something um uh like that's that's totally free to change or if it's in something that's in an unreleased product that's that's you know totally uh totally fine or you know when you are selecting a name for something new um it is totally free for you to just pick a different name um yeah if you've got some readme file that says uh blacklisted, that doesn't cost anything.
更好的例子是，如果你只是在文档中使用某个东西。那是绝对 100% 免费的。如果它只是你用来描述某事的一个词，更改它完全是免费的。或者如果它位于你用来描述某事的东西中……就像那样……完全是免费更改的，或者如果它位于尚未发布的产品中，那你知道的，完全……完全没问题，或者你知道的，当你为新事物选择名称时，你完全可以自由选择一个不同的名字……是的，如果你有一些写着“黑名单（blacklisted）”的 readme 文件，改掉它没有任何成本。
Yeah. Anyways, I said not to go on a digression, although I was very curious about your thoughts on the first class thing. Yeah, I have been spending a lot of time thinking about this lately because I sort of accidentally fell into putting it together, you know, being the person that's doing the drafting for this document for Insights. So I've been spending a good chunk of time the past few months working on that. Yeah, it's, you know, it's important stuff, especially when you hear, you know, the context behind a word that you had no idea, you know. Like you said, I hear grandfathered and I think, oh, it's just gendered. Is there a gender neutral? Then you find out, oh, it actually comes from this. And you're like, oh, yeah, humans suck and we should do better.
是的。无论如何，我说过不要偏离主题，虽然我对你关于 first-class 的想法非常好奇。是的，我最近花了很多时间思考这个问题，因为我有点偶然地开始着手整理它，你知道的，作为为 Insights 编写这篇文档的人。所以在过去的几个月里，我花了大把时间在上面。是的，这……你知道的，这是很重要的事，特别是当你听到你完全不了解的某个词背后的背景时。就像你说的，我听到 grandfathered，然后我想，哦，这只是有性别倾向。有没有中性的？然后你发现，哦，它实际上来自这个，然后你会想，哦，是的，人类真烂，我们应该做得更好。
I was reminded of its importance this week when it came up in the context of a C++ committee proposal for a data structure that is currently called Stood Colony. And it actually sort of illustrates an interesting facet of what we're doing here. There's a bunch of terms on this list of terms to avoid that at first glance, they might seem like they're not something that would ever come up in a tech standard.
本周当它出现在 C++ 委员会提案的背景下时，我想到了它的重要性，该提案涉及一种目前被称为 std::colony 的数据结构。它实际上在某种程度上说明了我们在这里所做事情的一个有趣方面。这份要避免的术语清单上有一堆术语，乍一看，它们似乎永远不会出现在技术标准中。
We have cast on that list, and we have widow and orphan on that list. Those ones are a little bit more obvious, but, um, uh, you know, something like colony, you might think, you know, that's not really a tech term, right? You know, like it's not a common name for a data structure. It happens to be the name of this data structure, but, um, you know, it's unlikely to come up, but as it turns out, like you'd be surprised, um, uh, you know, when, in, when, when tech standards and programmers are searching for a good name for something, they will, you know, uh, look at all of the possible options and, uh, that might include things that you hadn't previously thought of. And so it just like, it reminded me of the importance of this, where I was like, oh yeah, that's, I had not previously thought about that one. That one is kind of problematic. And this perfectly illustrates why we need to not only have guidelines for, like when we not need to,
我们名单上有 cast（类型转换），我们名单上有 widow（孤行）和 orphan（孤行），这些稍微明显一点，但是，你知道的，像 colony 这样的词，你可能会想，你知道的，这其实不是一个技术术语，对吧？你知道，它不是数据结构的常用名称。它刚好是这个数据结构的名称，但是，你知道的，它不太可能会出现，但事实证明，你会感到惊讶，你知道的，当技术标准和程序员在为某个东西寻找好名字时，他们会，你知道的，查看所有可能的选项，而这可能包括你以前没有想到的事情。所以这就像，它提醒了我这件事情的重要性，当时我想，哦，对了，我以前没有想过那个。那个确实有点问题。这就完美地说明了为什么我们不仅需要制定准则，比如当我们需要时，
why we need to not only have a list of terms that are problematic but also like guidelines for thinking about this because the list is never going to be comprehensive and so are you saying that stood colony is going to get uh axed i think it is unlikely that that will be called stood colony interesting do you i'm just curious or is there a leading, or is this like hot off the press? There's like 150 email deep thread discussing the names here. I think there were other the name colony conforms with the ISO and Insights rules with regards to inclusive terminology, because we've had a number of people who have objected to it. So, yeah, I don't think it'll be called colony. I think it'll be called something else.
为什么我们不仅需要一份有问题术语的清单，还需要思考这些问题的准则，因为这份清单永远不会面面俱到。所以你是说 std::colony 要被砍掉了吗？我认为它不太可能被命名为 std::colony。有意思。你……我只是好奇，还是说这算是个新鲜出炉的消息？有一个深达 150 封邮件的线程在讨论这里的名字。我认为还有其他的……colony 这个名字符合 ISO 和 Insights 关于包容性术语的规则，因为我们有很多反对它的人。所以，是的，我认为它不会被称为 colony。我想它会被叫别的名字。
All right. what we'll do is I'm gonna cut this whole inclusive language bit, because now we've probably been talking about this for like 20 plus minutes, into its own episode, and we'll call it, I don't know, something like inclusive inclusivity in language or something. Oh, but we're not even done with the Excel stuff. I still got
好吧。我们要做的，是把这整段关于包容性语言的内容剪辑出来——因为现在我们大概已经谈了 20 多分钟了——把它做成单独的一集，我们把它叫做，我不知道，类似于“语言中的包容性”之类的标题。哦，但我们甚至还没讲完 Excel 的内容呢。我还有
two or three more. Yeah, so you're gonna hear me say, is that inclusive? And then I'm gonna cut in myself saying, turns out it's not. Stay tuned for next time. But back to Excel. And then we'll loop back to this point now. So I'm not, yeah, I'm going to go on a brief spiel on another thing, which is what I believe is one of the core principles of inclusive terminology, at least within the context of standards, this principle makes sense. it it's not a question so when we're dealing with standards we're often looking for consensus and uh consensus doesn't mean majority vote um it's most supposed to mean that you know
两三个要讲。所以，你将会听到我说，“这具有包容性吗？”然后我会插入我自己说，“事实证明并非如此。请收听下期节目。”但回到 Excel。然后我们现在再循环回到这个点。所以我不……是的，我要就另一件事发表简短的演讲，那就是我认为包容性术语的核心原则之一，至少在标准的语境下，这个原则是有意义的。这不是一个问题……所以当我们处理标准时，我们经常在寻求共识，而共识并不意味着多数投票，
everybody agrees but um consensus means neither a tyranny of the majority nor a tyranny of the minority so it means you can't just have the majority of people vote out the minority. And you also can't have the minority, you know, indefinitely hold up the majority. And we often are like, seek to make decisions by consensus. I mean, we're supposed to make all decisions by consensus. and so I was thinking about how does that play into making decisions about whether terms are inclusive or not and the conclusion I came to is it is not a question of you should not be asking the question do we have consensus that this term is problematic you should instead be asking the question is, do we have consensus
它的本意应该是，你知道的，每个人都同意，但共识既不意味着多数人的暴政，也不意味着少数人的暴政。这意味着你不能仅仅让多数人投票排除少数人。你也不能让少数人无限期地阻挠多数人。我们经常寻求通过共识做出决策。我的意思是，我们应该通过共识做出所有决策。所以我一直在思考这如何影响关于术语是否具有包容性的决策，我得出的结论是，这不是一个问题，你不应该问这样一个问题：我们是否对该术语是有问题的达成共识？你反而应该问这个问题：我们是否有共识
that the term is not problematic? So the reason that the distinction is important there is we need, it's a different bar. The bar of consensus that the term is problematic is a much higher one. It requires essentially everybody to agree that it is problematic. The bar of consensus that it's not problematic means that if there is a sustained minority that has a sustained objection, so a smallish part of the group, not the entire group, but a notable chunk of the group has a sustained objection that after discussion there's no resolution to, then you don't have consensus. That's a very different bar from trying to convince everybody that it is problematic.
认为该术语没有问题？这种区别之所以重要，是因为我们需要……这是一个不同的标准。认为该术语有问题的共识标准要高得多。它本质上要求每个人都同意它是有问题的。认为它没有问题的共识标准意味着，如果存在一个持续反对的少数派，即群体中较小的一部分，而不是整个群体，但群体中显著的一部分提出了持续的反对意见，在讨论后仍无法解决，那么你们就没有达成共识。这与试图说服所有人它是有问题的标准有着极大的不同。
It flips it so that instead, if you want to use a particular term and some people think it's problematic, you would need to convince them that it's fine instead of them convincing you that the term is problematic. So it's sort of the difference between innocent until proven guilty or guilty until proven innocent. And I think that's one of the key principles that folks should keep in mind. And the other one that is important is that it's not a question of whether the term is objectively problematic. And you should avoid entering discussions about whether it's objectively problematic because the reason that we avoid problematic terms is because they might be harmful or hurtful or evoke negative feelings or emotions among certain people. Non-inclusive terms, it's all
这将其颠倒了过来，因此，如果你想使用某个特定的术语，而有些人认为它有问题，你需要说服他们这个词没问题，而不是让他们说服你这个词有问题。所以这有点像“未经证明有罪前即为无罪”和“未经证明清白前即认为有罪”的区别。我认为这是人们应该牢记的关键原则之一。另一个重要的原则是，这并非关于该术语是否“客观上”有问题。并且你应该避免陷入讨论它是否客观上有问题的争端，因为我们避免使用有问题的术语的原因是它们可能会伤害、冒犯某些人，或者在某些人中引起负面的感觉或情绪。非包容性的术语，这完全
about the experience of, you know, impacted individuals, their subjective experience. It's not about whether it's objectively, you know, problematic or not. If somebody is experiencing it, experiencing negative, you know, associations with that term, it doesn't matter, you know, their reason. If they're legitimately experiencing that, then that is sufficient for it to be a non-inclusive term. And as soon as we get into the world of trying to objectively determine whether a term is problematic or not, then it becomes a litigation of somebody who's probably from an underrepresented minority in that group and who might have strong personal reactions to the problematic term. And there's just no good that's going to come of trying to litigate that. So I think essentially to summarize what I'm saying is that you sort of got to take people at their word. It's sort of a question of does anybody object to this? And if anybody does,
取决于受影响个人的体验，即他们的主观体验。这与它是否客观上有问题无关。如果有人正在经历、体验到与该术语相关的负面联想，那么他们的理由并不重要。如果他们确实有这种真实的体验，这就足以让它成为一个非包容性的术语。一旦我们陷入试图客观确定一个术语是否有问题的世界，那就变成了对某个人的诉讼，而这个人可能来自该群体中代表性不足的少数群体，并且可能对该有问题的术语有强烈的个人反应。试图通过诉讼来解决这个问题不会带来任何好处。所以我认为本质上，总结我的观点，你基本上得相信人们的话。这有点像一个问题：有没有人反对这个？如果有任何人反对，
we're just going to go and find some other term. We're not going to litigate whether the objection, whether we all personally you know believe in that objection it is sufficient that there are people here that object to that yeah and i think the only thing i'll add because those are both great points is for the first one when talking about consensus is not to forget to if you're in a room to look around the room and see if you have a good representation of all folks in your community. Because you can quickly reach consensus with, you know, a bunch of people that look exactly the same as you in the room. And that's, I think that's probably one of the biggest mistakes, at least in, you know, the last, or i don't know how many how many years but it's just i think people think that they're they're doing a great job and they just no one has pointed out the fact
我们就会去寻找其他的术语。我们不会去打官司来争论反对意见是否合理，我们是否都亲自相信那个反对意见，只要这里有人反对，那就足够了。是的，我要补充的唯一一点——因为这两点都很棒——是关于第一点，在谈论共识时，不要忘记，如果你在一个房间里，环顾四周，看看你的社区中是否所有人都有良好的代表性。因为你很容易与房间里一群外表和你完全一模一样的人达成共识。我认为这可能是最大的错误之一，至少在过去……或者我不知道多少年里，人们只是认为他们做得很好，只是没有人指出
that hey there's no insert uh underrepresented uh you know demographic in the room and so everyone thinks oh great thumbs up we did a great job high fives all around and it's not until you know we we launch something and then it it hits a bunch of users and oh yeah we missed that why did we miss that well we didn't have anyone in the room that would have pointed that out to us um yeah but yeah very important stuff it's like inception it's like inception there's a podcast inside the podcast that's where we'll end it thanks for listening have a great day and we'll see you in the next episode There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
嘿，房间里没有纳入某个代表性不足的人口统计群体，所以每个人都想，哦太棒了，竖起大拇指，我们干得好，大家击掌庆祝，直到我们推出某个东西，然后它触及了一大批用户，哦，天哪，我们漏掉了这个，为什么我们漏掉了？因为房间里没有任何人会向我们指出这一点……是的，但非常重要的事情，这就像《盗梦空间》一样，就像《盗梦空间》里套着播客。这就是我们要结束的地方。感谢收听，祝你有美好的一天，我们下期节目见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。